hey everyone this is Lucy and today
we're back with another highly requested
video topic which is what to do after
getting an ABS certification now if
you've recently completed an AWS
certification then I want to
congratulate you on your achievement
passing these exams take a lot of hard
work and dedication and so you should be
very proud of yourself but I get it
you're now sitting there with your shiny
new certificate thinking okay what next
how should I use this to L A Cloud job
well you've come to the right place
because in this video I'm going to share
my advice and tips to help you get the
most out of your certification for those
who are new here my name is Lucy I'm an
X AWS Solutions architect and over the
past 2 years I've studied for and
achieved five ads certifications on this
channel I teach people how they can do
the same by providing study road maps
and career guidance so if that sounds
like something you're interested in
please make sure you give this video a
like And subscribe to this channel to
stay updated all right let's get into it
so Ed certifications like most it
certifications have a bit of a mixed
reputation in the tech industry some
people love them While others think
think they're a complete waste of time I
sit somewhere in the middle because even
though adbs certifications don't teach
you everything they provide you with a
structured learning part to learn the
fundamentals plus if you add them to
your LinkedIn profile it can help you
stand out to potential employers but are
ads certifications enough to learn your
Cloud job not really the bad news is
most certifications won't provide you
with a complete understanding of the
cloud this is because the questions in
the exams are multiple choice and are
based on specific facts and figures that
you can just memorize it doesn't force
you to actually get handson and learn
how to deploy the core AWS Services
which is a bit of a problem because
those are the skills needed for most
technical roles like Solutions
Architects and Cloud engineers and so
how do you bridge that gap between
certifications and what you need to
learn a cloud job the secret lies in
these Three Steps step number one gain
some real hands-on experience step
number two is to get some relevant
industry knowledge and step number three
is to network and build your community
by following these three steps you'll be
able to stand out from other job Seekers
who are also AWS certified all right
let's dive deeper and break down these
steps one at a time so the first step
after getting an ads certification is to
gain hands-on experience in your
certification study you might have
created an adbs account and played
around with some services but in order
to fully understand the adbs services
and to get to the level that tech
companies are looking for you'll need to
gain some hands-on experience with
building architectures and Solutions in
the cloud now there are three main ways
to gain this experience the first one is
through guided tutorials this is a great
starting point for beginners and these
tutorials provide you with the exact
step-by-step instructions for example
this tutorial on how to build a basic
web application you can see that it
takes about 35 minutes to complete and
can be done for free if you'd like to
check out some of these tutorials I
recommend visiting workshops. AWS for a
set of over 100 free ad slabs and
tutorials the second way to gain this
hands-on experience is through Cloud
projects unlike certifications where you
follow exact step-by-step instructions
Cloud projects allow you to be more
creative and build something end to end
for example you can can build a 3T web
application on AWS or build a custom
chat bot that your friends can talk to I
have a video on my channel where I walk
through three beginner friendly AWS
Hands-On projects so make sure you take
a look if you're interested the third
way to gain hands-on experience is
through freelancing this is where you
can go on to platforms like Fiverr or
upwork to see freelance projects where
people may need help on things related
to AWS now I know what some of you might
be thinking Lucy I don't have work
experience how can I start freelancing
the good news is you don't need to have
much experience to begin with you can
offer your services at a lower rate and
build a portfolio of work as you go
along for example you can start by
helping people with no Tech experience
host their website on AWS but yeah
freelance projects can give you a chance
to work on real world problems that
businesses are facing which can then
help you grow your Cloud skills even
further speaking of building Real World
experience the second step after getting
an AWS certification is to gain relevant
industry knowledge but let me start by
saying this the names of ads
certifications can often be misleading
just because in ads certification ation
is listed as Solutions architect for
example doesn't mean you have to become
a Solutions architect these
certifications teach you the relevant
Concepts to become devops engineers
Solutions Architects Cloud Engineers or
even software developers each of these
roles require specific skills outside of
the certification for example as to
become a software developer you'll need
to know how to code but the core ads
knowledge and services remain the same
and so what I'm trying to say is don't
limit yourself to one or two particular
roles research the different roles out
there in the tech Cloud industry before
deciding which role you want to aim for
because trust me there are so many cool
roles where you can use your knowledge
of ads to help others another way to
help you gain insight into the tech
industry is through career mentorship if
you're looking for a personal mentor to
help you learn your dream job I'd highly
recommend checking out pathrise pathrise
is a career mentorship program that
matches you with a dedicated career
mentor to guide you along your job
search Journey the network of mentors
help you optimize your resume help you
prepare for interviews and answer any
career related questions you may have
you can pretty much get unlimited
oneon-one time with an expert in the
field you want to get into they have
different industry tracks available for
example software engineering data and it
and cyber security path has helped
thousands of fellows from all sorts of
backgrounds landar great jobs in Tech
and the best part is you don't have to
pay anything before you get hired this
means the program is 100% free before
you landar a job to get started head to
pathways.com for/ tewi Lucy to get match
with a career Mentor today I'll also
have a link to this in the description
below thank you pathwise for partnering
with me on this video okay the third
step after getting an ads certification
is to network and build your community
networking is not only important for
helping you learn a job but also having
a successful career in Tech to meet
people who are also interested in
learning AWS I'd recommend joining a
local AWS User Group you can see here
that there are more than 400 user groups
around the world including the US Canada
India South Africa and so on and so
definitely check out this website to see
if there's a local group near You by
attending some of these events you'll be
able to slowly make new friends and
build your network another great way to
meet people who are working in cloud and
it is through Tech conferences many of
them are free to attend to keep an eye
out on those as well one of my favorite
quotes is your network is your net worth
this really emphasizes that networking
isn't just something to help you find a
job it can also help you make new
friends and build relationships that can
provide you with a lifetime of learning
and growth before we wrap up there's one
more thing I'd like to mention so I
recently started a free email newsletter
called Cloud bites. a where every week I
share the latest news and advice on
cloud and artificial intelligence so if
you find my videos helpful you might
want to subscribe to the newsletter all
right this brings us to the end of this
video please give this video a like if
you found it useful and I'll see you in
the next one bye for
now